[Music]
this is awkward to admit but my mom's
ashes are in my attic i just don't know
what i can legally do with them what are
my options besides keeping a loved one
on my mantel ryan did some illegal stuff
with my mom's ashes
no i didn't
uh but i would put random name tags on
the ashes
we had fun with it it was and it was
like the smallest little urn yeah i
don't know what did you do with like the
majority of her ashes i just mixed my
coffee every morning oh my god so now
she's with you
oh god
uh no seriously what did you do with
like the majority of rashes i um
that's right yeah and then you kept a
little urn for yourself well then i
spread those in dayton eventually and
got rid of the urn as well yeah which
because my mom was not in the urn
right
i didn't even question
but is that is it legal to spread ashes
is it technically illegal to spread
someone's ashes i'm not telling you to
spread ashes or not spread ashes you're
just talking about what you've done yeah
it's been over seven years yeah i think
it actually depends on the area i mean
there's some places that kind of look
down on it like i had looked into
there's a place the highest place in
tennessee
is in the smoky mountains called
clingmans dome
and yeah
you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah um and this is a place but yeah
it's a place i was really fascinated
with as a youth and i thought oh i think
when i pass i would like to be cremated
and have my ashes spread with there
well
it's national park service right
they
legally
you can't do that now do people go up
though and wait till no one's around and
do things like that of course they do
yeah legally though that's an area where
yeah it's a little gray area yeah so
part of my mom is swimming the
uh tampa bay which is kind of surprising
i gotta say real quick i want to
interrupt you on that though because
your mom was was catholic right
that um of course my family's catholic
as well and when my dad passed
they're very like the catholics they're
fine with cremation
the specifics are though you have to
keep all the ashes together
and at some point the ashes have to be
buried in a catholic cemetery
those are like as far as catholicism
those are the specifics well i feel like
your mom was catholic no my mom was like
was she the cat like was she uber
catholic okay so she
here's how catholic she was she went to
church six days a week she just didn't
go on sundays because that's when the
fake catholics went she said wow yeah
she was so catholic because like she was
a nun before she had me right okay
and she was still practicing catholic
when
she had keys to the church that's how
catholic mom was wow
and
but what i'll say is that she didn't
really buy into certain dogmas like that
and
and she said well once i'm gone i'm gone
i'm gonna be in heaven and my ashes are
just my ashes my body's my body it's
sort of like in my will
my will says that like you and bex can
decapitate me shoot my body out of a
cannon use my head as a soccer ball
it literally says this in my will yeah
it does and wow
and i'm the one that gets to decide
so excited
if it brings you great joy oh that'd be
wonderful right we're gonna have a
soccer game yeah for your funeral
i love it
and so yes i guess part of my mom was
swimming around tampa bay and then every
time i'd go over to ryan's condo i'd
sprinkle a few ashes on his carpet oh my
god i felt like i was getting haunted
do i have any serious uh
uh for janine
um i think he said the best about
the the the ashes are not
uh
your mother is not in those ashes i mean
physically yes there are some you know
burnt flesh that is there but like
that's not your mom
and
with that said it's like you can do with
them whatever you want like yeah i would
encourage you to do something that has
meaning
um but even if you don't that's okay
yeah and by the way meaning can mean
different things to you like ryan and i
jokingly when i had the little urn he
would come over put little name tags on
it and like
he had a name tag that said chloe and
then because originally before the one
that said alex
and i'm like oh we should at least put
her name on it and so like
and and so it had a a like a customer
service name tag like
we would talk to her
and and so like worst customer service
agent ever
why are you stonewalling me
anyway she uh
she was there in spirit but we knew that
there wasn't the person
there
hiding in the urn
and so
it was meaningful to me and ryan because
one of the ways that we dealt with
tragedy is through levity and being
willing to joke about something as
profoundly sad as losing a parent
is one way to grieve yeah and your mom
would have she would have laughed it oh
she would have loved it yeah yeah and so
i guess i would throw this question back
on janine and say what do you feel
compelled to do and not compelled by
society like you're supposed to bury the
urn or or you're supposed to
be in a particular cemetery or you're
supposed to have ashes on a mantel
like that was the joy i had a mantle in
my apartment so that was the only thing
on the mantel was that little tiny urn
yeah
it's not what society
says you're supposed to do what do you
feel compelled to do
and you can let go in a way that is most
compelling to you and i would
just briefly jump in um so i joked
around with my i felt the same way about
my ashes even though i was raised
catholic i just told
my wife diane and i said you know creamy
i really don't care what you do
afterwards because i'll be gone i mean
my body's left right the bones will be
the cremation but i really don't care
what you do with it because i'll be dead
uh but
um
because i said you can put me in one of
those like soup little soup containers
or something
uh but i thought for an idea i had later
though i thought for the family if it's
something they wanted uh more than
burying me in a cemetery or something
like that i said
put my ashes i dig a hole put my ashes
in the hole
plant a tree over me
now there's something that's a living
thing that's going to benefit in some
way right from my my remains and i in a
way become part of that living thing
that if
future generations of the family want to
visit yeah they could be a relative yes
and if it's an apple tree they could eat
podcast shawn
it's a new variety of apple it's gonna
be a bitter ass tree let's say that
better
well they actually do have that um i've
seen that where they will
you can basically yeah you can put your
body in a
a whole tree system and like grow a tree
out of your like you know you
use your body as fertilizer essentially
that's a beautiful way to do it as
opposed to the ash because the ashes
aren't going to do much but if you have
an actual decomposing body right it can
provide
fertile fertile soils for something to
grow right now here's what i'll say one
last thing
janine did your mom tell you what she
wanted done with her ashes and if so was
it reasonable
because here's what you don't want to do
with her ashes she's like please
whatever you do don't spread me
throughout the tampa bay sorry mom
right but as long as it was reasonable
what did she want yeah did she
communicate that with you
and also what was her tradition because
i also want to be respectful of other
religious traditions and if someone else
is like hey here's what i would like you
to do with my ashes as long as it's
reasonable i would respect that if
they're asking for something
unreasonable that's a different story
but i would do anything within reason
had my mom asked but she
she specifically said she wanted to be
spread in the tampa bay and therefore
she was yeah allegedly as long as that's
not illegal wait we're past the statute
of limitations that's right yeah you can
admit it now take that city of st
petersburg
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free